how are you in California I'm praying
yourself better than I deserve what's up
so we have three options we can choose
right now it's either option one to stay
the course and go baby step two option
to pause the baby steps and pay off my
mom's credit card first and then
continue the baby step and then option
three go into storm mode because this
month we'll be turning in the waiver to
imitation and it'll take about six
months to a year to know if he's denied
or approved you'll be turning in the
waiver for what for immigration for my
husband's legal status oh okay and why
are you paying them when it stops or why
are you paying off your mom's credit
card
we borrowed her credit card and 2016 to
pay for our wedding and we borrowed it
again when my husband almost cut off his
right hand alright so you're gonna have
to stop that aren't you oh yeah yeah we
we found you about six months ago how
much do you owe your mother for the use
of her credit card we have six thousand
less on it okay how much money do you
have any I'm like saved up yeah just the
emergency from the one thousand that's
how you work in the baby steps one of
your debts is repaying your mom and and
your husband's immigration status comes
into play how do you need money for that
uh yeah one other a baby step the
smallest baby steps alone as a lawyer so
we're almost that's actually the first
one on the list so if he gets denied
more than likely he will get deported
and so he wants to go into storm mode
save as much money as you can in case he
gets deported and I want to just do baby
optional and just follow baby step two
so what is the probability fifty
50 that he gets deported 90 10 Oh I mean
he is a immigration and as the ice
prince came out clean but it there's
always a 50-50 no that's just worrying I
mean what is your lawyer telling you
this is a slam dunk
I don't know I don't know this stuff I
mean he has he has a good outcome he
says he thinks that everything's going
to be okay
okay so that's not 50/50 that's yeah
well for him no yeah I'm not asking
about worrying I'm asking about what
really is going to happen you can worry
about dying when you walk out across the
street but your probability of that
happening is not 50/50 you see what I'm
saying
one that and that's how you make these
decisions you don't make financial
decisions off of wringing your hands
about vague things
this isn't vague but I don't know enough
about immigration law to tell you
whether you watch your probabilities are
I really don't and so so your husband
wants to pay the law your not pay your
mom and pile up cash to get ready for a
pawnbroker mode yeah yeah when will when
will you know about his immigration
status I take six months to a year from
today from but we turn it in on the 24th
of this month oh that's a long time yeah
and what's your household income okay I
would think that in six months to a year
that you should be able to pay off the
lawyer of the six thousand dollars and
pile up some money yeah I think so too
so stopping and actually that puts you
in the best position if he did get
deported because if you were dead free
and had a pile of money versus if you
just had a pile of money that would not
be a good position so yeah let's go
ahead and just work the plan but let's
work it with incredible
intensity lots of overtime and no
spending at all because we've got to get
this this debt paid and get it off of
you because it's a big deal problem
emotionally with it being owed to your
mom or on her credit card god help us
with that if you ever use that again you
need to be smacked okay don't do that
okay gotta get you that but how much is
the lawyer oh we have 1600 left on it
that's what I want to do just continue
the baby steps I think you work the
lawyer then you work mom and then you
pile up cash and you do it with great
intensity because I think in six months
you're gonna have five to ten thousand
dollars worth of cash and no debt and in
a year you for sure would okay and if
you got a year that's six months to a
year to find out now if you can get
different news and something different
happens then you would stop everything
in pile up cash right if you've got
actual facts not just fears you know
it's like someone calling me and saying
I think I'm going to lose my job why I
don't know I just sometimes people lose
their jobs you know well no you don't
stop on that basis oh they laid off 60%
of the people and they said they're
gonna do another wave next week okay
that's different we stopped everything
cuz you're probably gonna lose your job
you know and we can we stop everything
and build up an emergency fund but
that's how you analyze this stuff is
what are the real probabilities that
simple hey thanks for the call